[music playing]
NARRATOR: The use of
such enormous blocks
is the main reason many of
these ancient structures,
like the walls at Thera,
have survived until today.
But why was it so important that
they remain standing thousands
of years into the future?
There was an architect here
who had complete understanding
of stone, of
masonry, and that you
can do extraordinary things with
it that would last a lifetime
and forever.
Not only did they actually build
things which were guaranteed
to last, often they're
working with unusual angles,
and they're so tightly fitted,
that earthquakes find it very
difficult to break them apart.
In fact, they are
earthquake-proof.
NARRATOR: Ancient astronaut
theorists point out
that other common design
elements were incorporated
in structures
throughout the world
to ensure their longevity,
including the widespread use
of metal braces inserted
into keystone cuts
to reinforce ancient
constructions.
This unusual way of
fitting large stones together
is found in ancient Egypt.
It's found in ancient Ethiopia.
It is found in India and
Greece, and in Italy.
It is found at Angkor
Wat in Cambodia.
It's found at the
Composites in Vietnam.
And we find it in Peru, at
Ollantaytambo, and at Cuzco.
And we see it also at Tiwanaku
and Puma Punku in Bolivia.
FREDDY SILVA: The two stones
essentially have a channel dug
in between them, and there's
a certain slot into which
is poured molten metal.
Now, this brings up
all kinds of questions,
because, one, alloys
were not supposed
to have been discovered
until about 2,500 BC.
The fact that these stones
go back to at least 13,000
BC creates a huge problem.
We have here, again, sheer
technology crossing huge span
of time in order to make sure
that the stones never ever
fall apart.
Now, people working on
different sides of the world,
trying to build similar
things, are not necessarily
going to think of the
same way to build it,
in certain respects.
The similarities in the way
some of the stones were cut,
the keystone, other factors
that people wouldn't necessarily
think of, for them to show up,
and for them to be used to give
greater duration to
these structures,
way beyond any
reasonable expectation
that the people living then were
going to continue to use these,
tells us that there's somebody
maybe with a longer time span
was behind the design
of these things.
Whoever was behind the
design wanted these things
to last a really long time.
Who were the teachers of
these engineering styles?
The only conclusion
there is is that aliens
had a hand in these
creations a long time ago.
They're all human made,
but with the assistance
or the technology provided
by extraterrestrials.